cbs news chief political analyst john
dickerson john good morning
anthony we heard ed o'keefe say that the
white house is signaling they don't
expect major developments out of this
but this is a relationship the u.s and
russia that's been spiraling downward
for
a while now both sides saying it's at a
low point
is there a possibility of stabilizing
the relationship at least well that's
the really important thing is stability
58 years ago almost to the day u.s
officials and russian officials met in
geneva to work out the hotline
with the red phone it wasn't an actual
red phone but to why did they do it for
two reasons one was communication
they needed to be able for adversaries
to exchange messages quickly so there
were no misunderstandings that's the
second thing is nora was talking about
cyber attacks
the u.s has to be sure and russia has to
be sure exactly what the red lines are
on these cyber attacks so that something
doesn't spiral out of control
that's stability among among adversaries
but that's important so
they could work out some of that and
then there are these nuclear issues
these prisoner issues
there's obviously ukraine there are a
whole host of issues where
the u.s wants to say here are our
priorities and that's really important
for the russians to know what u.s
priorities are what the red lines are
and then also to know what the russians
might do to get back in the us's good
graces and vice versa joe biden is a new
president but these two men have a prior
relationship there is a history it is
interesting to note
i think the wording that joe biden has
used about mr putin i mean at one time
of course not long ago he called him a
killer
but then he just said recently they
called him a worthy adversary which
seemed to be a tonal shift
sure and you see so so president biden
is playing games you can imagine
president putin who likes to play games
in these meetings
uh extending the length of the meeting
in other words he likes to
show his physical prowess he's going to
do an ironman maybe
uh approach to today you know um stretch
it out there will be a lot of
gamesmanship but i thought
word of the adversary was quite
interesting too because the president's
been criticized for giving putin a
meeting as if it's some kind of prize
and to be called a word the adversary by
an american president for putin who
wants
to look on parity with an american
president is a kind of
gift in advance of this form of respect
in some ways exactly
which means when they get behind closed
doors you would expect perhaps the
president to say look i
i've shown you respect there here are
the things you need to hear me on
in this private way uh sort of playing
an inside game and announcement there's
a meeting going on but there are
parameters for the meeting as we
understand it the men will be together
for hours along with staff but
no meal will be shared they will never
be alone together and then afterwards
there will be no joint press conference
that's a lot of choreography why
it is well and think about the last time
that a president met with vladimir putin
when president trump met with him
it was the exact opposite it was
unscripted it was harem scarum it was
not as tightly controlled and the reason
it has to be tightly controlled again
is to make sure there are no
misunderstandings that both sides need
to know exactly what they're saying to
each other
and that's just that's about the moment
but it's also for six months from now
so that when vladimir putin is making
choices about what he's going to do
he can have in his mind the recollection
of what they said in those meetings and
the same is true for the for president
biden as well
and so you just it has to be
choreographed so that there's no
misunderstanding because
inside the misunderstanding is where you
have things go wrong now president biden
has been on quite the trip
of the tour of europe what is the
significance you think of this coming on
the heels of the g7
and nato where a unified front was
presented so president ryden keeps
saying and all this stuff keeps saying
america is back
what does that mean it means that the
president is putting himself forward
as the kind of the lead spokesman for a
whole set of values that basically
established the liberal order
in international relations over the last
70 80 years
so it's not just u.s russia relations
it's president biden saying i am here as
the representative of the most powerful
democracy on the planet
and here's what we believe and these
aren't just abstract notions
i have countries behind me i have the
nato alliance behind me
and that gives force to what i say that
is both a public message
but it's also private i mean when i
asked dr condoleeza rice the former
secretary of state how to measure this
she said don't look at the pageantry
watch six months later if the private
messages have paid off
what would we look for lower fewer cyber
attacks
maybe some improvement on the human
rights front
but those private messages are going to
be the most interesting and unfortunate
we won't learn about those for about six
months or so
john we're looking as you're speaking at
president biden's motorcade on its way
to the meeting with
president putin what how successful has
president biden been so far do you think
on this trip and
and what constitutes success in this
meeting with vladimir putin yeah
well that's a great point we'll start
with putin as i was saying about
former secretary rice her point was
success is
if he can convey in these private
meetings this is what is important in
the united states and
this is what we know you're up to he can
president
biden can talk about intelligence and
about what the u.s really knows the
russians are up to and can say
if you keep going down this road here is
the retaliation you can expect
again predictability because in
misunderstanding you can have a real
particularly with cyber it can go
haywire fast so
unfortunately a lot of that we won't be
able to measure in the moment and we
might not be able to measure
four months part of evaluating the
president's performance will be what did
vladimir putin get out of this so
what does putin hope to bring home to
russia politically what does he need to
do or want to do here
well he's already brought it home which
is being called a worthy adversary as
anthony mentioned by the u.s president
he wants to look like
he wants to be able to say look i can
meddle in ukraine i can
imprison my political opponents and i
pay no penalty for it so strength works
now the white house knows that they know
they're giving him that little bit
but what they've made the calculation is
it's worth giving
putin that because what we want is
clarity and we want him to stop behaving
in the way
he is and the only way we can get a shot
at doing that is if we deliver these
messages privately to him but doesn't
putin still need the united states for
his home audience and say look there's
the big enemy out there they're enemy
number one i've kept you safe keep me in
power for another decade
sure he one foot on the gas one front of
the break so he'll say
they're the big enemy out there i am the
only one who can stand up to them but
when i do
i get this parody i get uh called a
worthy adversary and so
he can um put show some of those
bouquets that he's gotten
you know and so in that sense he wants
to look like he is
um chummy with the american president
that's chummy goes too far
but looks like he can um uh he's close
be at least uh on well on the same level
with an american president
which is um which is one that that
allows him to show look i can do both
things
for you the russian people so all of
this is happening as alexi navalny is in
prison in russia how does that play into
this
especially with putin kind of dismissing
uh
the issue when he was asked in an
interview about navalny recently well
this goes back to
and this is perhaps the trickiest part
for president biden and it goes back to
what he's been doing for the last
several days which is say i am the
leader of
the democracies and we care about human
rights fine so he talks about that
but what is it going to do how is it
going to pay off and if you keep
talking about human rights and don't put
any muscle behind it or it doesn't pay
off
then it weakens that message so in terms
of that public role
as the leader of a democracy namely's
case
and what the president says about it and
whether it pays off in any particular
way
is very important for the sort of public
theatrical part of this diplomacy we've
talked about the private messages
but in a very public way a u.s president
who
puts the hammer down on human rights has
to have some kind of a payoff and it'll
be fascinating to see
how that goes john quickly uh if you're
uh president biden what stick do you
have to hold over vladimir putin to say
stop with the cyber warfare stop
meddling in u.s election
i think you you and we know where you
live which is
we can look into exactly what these
russian hackers are doing why they're
related to you
and we know you have companies and i
mean you could imagine all the way into
your gas pipelines
we know how to turn them on and we know
how to turn them off and if you don't
stop
you're going to start having lots of
little accidents in russia that you
don't
know the origin of i mean i'm making
this up but this is the kind of private
threat that that a president can send
that we won't hear about
but that could convey a strong message
all right john dickerson thank you so
much